starting off this hour is chase in Texas
hi chase welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
mr. ND thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I currently am making
33 a year take home and I just about
landed a new job that is going to lose
my income by about 12 K why I'm worrying
what do I do with the difference and
money I haven't really have I never had
to deal with the extra that much of a
job why what happens yeah I know I mean
it's a good problem to have
hey man good for you how old are you 23
what's the new job law enforcement oh
very cool
good for you very cool so we teach folks
to do and what I learned to do years ago
back when I was in your decade chase was
actually to give every dollar an
assignment every dollar that does not
have a mission written beside it an
assignment before the month begins tends
to just freakin disappear if you don't
tell money whether it were to go you
will always wonder where it went
and that's called a budget every month
before the month begins get and get your
every dollar app out seven million
people are using it now it's free and
download that app and you can build out
your budget in about ten minutes
regardless of what you make and all you
have every dot you using it yep
okay then you're giving every dollar a
name god you're ahead of me okay yeah
once you're doing that then any money we
can find in the budget we apply to
whatever baby-step you are on do you
have any debt no and I've got four
months of savings right now so my
question is I really not ready to
consider moving out of where I am right
now it's a comfortable place I've got
plenty of time left on all these okay
and then you're fine so let's get to if
I should get to setting up retirement or
you get retirement going and I would get
retirement going and then I would do a
little bit of math that says how can I
save some money so
the next three or four years I buy a
house you don't the buy one today
but you do want to buy one in your 20s
and you got plenty time to do that so
you know if you start putting fifteen
percent of your income into retirement
that's baby step four which is where you
are how much can you save for retirement
and I mean for a house down payment and
so let's just make up a number you said
you got $12,000 raised let's just say
you did $12,000 a thousand dollars a
month going into an indoor mutual fund
for a house in two years you'd have
twenty four thousand and three years
you'd have thirty six thousand not not
County when it goes up in Vaes that'd be
pretty nice downpayment right oh
absolutely and you know you've got to
manage the other parts of your life like
if your car runs if the life starts
running out of your car it's laying down
you guys are saving up to buy a car
right you got to think about other stuff
every dollar has to have an assignment
and no debt and whatever it is you're
doing buying a house investing for
retirement going on vacation what going
on a date whatever it is you're doing
you're paying cash for it as you go
along and the good news is you've been
very wise to this point someone's taught
you well and you've been mature beyond
your years and it make good decisions to
this point now don't mess it up
you know take this new raise and give it
an assignment it's not a chance some
people think that whatever their new
raise equals to take-home pay per month
is how much their new car payment ought
to be some people they go spend
everything they make and if they make a
little more that means we have to go
spend it and you're not that guy so that
tells us how wise you are and how far
ahead of the game you are